notice how things change in our diagram
whereas previously we were copying all
the properties from card out methods
over to the new instance objects now
we're simply going to make those new
instance objects delegate their failed
lookups to card out methods this is an
important shift in that it allows us to
skip an expensive step of copying
properties over when we build a new
object it's interesting to note that if
Netscape hadn't pushed for adding Java
asked keywords and features to the
language way back in 1995 we might have
been writing code very much like this
for all of our JavaScript classes the
steps for making a class in this
prototype ol pattern are pretty clear
all you need is a function that allows
you to make instances a line in that
function that generates the new instance
object a delegation from the new object
to some prototype object and some logic
for augmenting the object with
properties that make it unique from all
the other objects of the same class
since this pattern is so common the
language designer decided to add
official conventions to support it you
see how we're making a methods object
here and adding it as a property of the
car function object if we plan to use
prototypes for all of our classes we'll
probably be doing this every time since
building a holder object for methods and
attaching it as a property to the
constructor function is so common the
language does this for you automatically
whenever a function is created it'll
have an object attached to it
that you can use as a container for
methods just in case you plan on using
that function to build instances of a
class the crazy thing is this
occasionally handy property the one the
language is going to build for you is
not stored at the key dot method
although we had chosen to store our
handy method container object at the key
dot methods the default object that
comes with every function is stored at
the key dot prototype it's just a naming
choice but it has been a very confusing
naming choice throughout the history of
the language and I'll explain why
but first let's refactor our code to
make use of the fact that we're given
this free dot prototype property where
we can store all of our methods since I
know this object is going to be created
for me and all I really need to do is
add a move method I can take out the
object literal and all I really need to
do is define this dot move method on
existing dot prototype object but car
dot methods doesn't exist anymore
so we need to refactor the rest of our
code to reflect the use of the provided
container object which is now stored at
car dot prototype